okay so this is the pre-lab video for
the pH indicator activity we are going
to do in class tomorrow so let's get
started so let's talk about a solution
really quick what's a solution well it's
a mixture where one substance dissolves
in another in my picture here's a beaker
of water if I were to add some sugar and
some kool-aid powder and get a spoon and
stir everything together the sugar the
kool-aid powder would dissolve within
the water and overall I would have a
pretty simple example here of a solution
it's a mixture where the sugar and the
kool-aid dissolved within the water so
when we talk about solutions some
solutions turn out to be an acid on the
pH scale and some solutions to anout to
be an alkaline or a base on the pH scale
so let's look at the pH scale you might
recognize here's our pH scale and
anything below the seven on the pH scale
is deemed an acid and anything above a
seven and the pH scale is deemed an
alkaline or a base and seven itself has
a neutral pH well what does it mean to
be an acid well it's a solution with a
large amount of hydrogen ions and a
small amount of hydroxide ions and a
base is really just the opposite and
alkaline is just the opposite an
alkaline or a base is a solution with a
small amount of hydrogen ions and a
large amount of hydroxide ions
well here's the payors a picture of a
solution right here how do I know if
this solution is an acid or a base I
mean I just have this you know beaker
full of you know purple colored liquid
right here what do I know how do I know
if it's an acid or a base what I can do
is I can use a pH indicator I can use an
indicator to figure out what what the pH
of it might be and this is going to get
to the purpose of our activity today so
what are then pH indicators
well pH indicators are chemicals
substances that will detect whether a
solution is an acid or a base and in
this activity we're gonna use six
different indicators one of them being
phenol red like the name implies it kind
of has a reddish color to it one of them
being phenolphthalein it's kind of a
clear transparent color to it
the third one being bromothymol blue
like the name implies has a blue blueish
color to it and then we're gonna come to
some that you might remember from middle
school blue litmus paper even though
it's called blue litmus paper it
actually kind of looks like a violet
color almost red litmus paper and even
though it's called red litmus paper it
almost has like a pinkish color to it
and then Universal litmus paper it kind
of looks like a light orange color and
so the goal is to determine which of
these six indicators will detect an acid
which of these six will detect the base
and want any of these detect both an
acid and a base let's go into that in a
little more detail here so how do pH
indicators then work well here is a
beaker of hydrochloric acid HCl as
hydrochloric acid now I already know
hydrochloric acid is an acid the word
acids in its name I'm not trying to
learn is hydrochloric acid an acid or is
hydrochloric acid a base I already know
hydrochloric acid is an acid well here's
a little container right here with two
little holes in it Oh what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna add a few drops of the
hydrochloric acid using my little
eyedropper here I'm gonna add a few
drops into the left side of this
container here so I've just added some
of the acid some of the hydrochloric
acid into that little hole right there
well here's a solution of sodium
hydroxide naoh is sodium hydroxide now
anytime you see the word hydroxide you
can pretty much assume that that's gonna
be a base so I already know I already
know sodium hydroxide is a base I'm not
trying to figure out I'm not trying to
figure out is sodium hydroxide an acid
or a base I already know it's a base so
what I'm gonna do is take a few drops
take my medicine dropper here take a few
drops of the sodium hydroxide and squirt
it into the other container the other
hole in the container
well now what now we're gonna use red
litmus paper because I think you're
familiar with litmus paper more than
maybe some of the other examples you saw
a moment ago so here's again red litmus
paper even though it's called red litmus
paper it actually has kind of almost a
pinkish color to it so here's a couple
pieces of red litmus paper now if I dip
these into the acid on the left and the
base on the right if I dip them into the
acid in the base how do these pieces of
paper communicate with me and being
silly right now do they verbally talk to
us does the one on the Left say I don't
feel anything when it's dipped into an
acid does the one on the right say oh
yeah this is definitely a base how do
these indicators actually communicate
with us because it's obviously not
verbal that's just silly
you might recall from middle school that
there might be a color change watch the
base watch the litmus paper on the right
that's been dipped into the base three
to one
notice what happened notice the how the
color changed from that pinkish color to
like a bluish color that's an indication
and that's why we call them indicators
that's an indication that there's been a
chemical change so I now know that red
litmus paper will turn colors when I put
it into a base so I can use for instance
red litmus paper to identify if
something's an acid or a base look on
the right so excuse me look on the left
side if you put red litmus paper into an
acid then no color changed so I know
that red litmus paper does not indicate
if something as an acid on the right
side I know that red litmus paper does
indicate if something as a base so right
now I know that red litmus paper will
indicate the presence of a base they
the color change and so the goal is
going to be to determine I have to go
through all six of these determine
whether red litmus paper will detect an
acid only well red litmus paper
detective base only or well red litmus
paper detect both acids and also bases I
have to go through all six indicators to
figure this out so then I go through the
other indicators blue litmus paper will
it detect the presence of an acid only
well it detect the presence of a base
only or does blue litmus paper detect
the presence of not just an acid but
also a base same for universal litmus
paper will it detect the presence of an
acid only well Universal litmus paper
detect the presence of a base only or
can Universal litmus paper detect the
presence of both an acid and a base same
then for phenol red will phenol red
detect the presence of an acid only well
phenol red detect the presence of a base
only or does phenol red detect the
presence of both an acid and also a base
and then same for phenolphthalein does
phenolphthalein detect the presence of
an acid only does phenolphthalein detect
the presence of a base only or does
phenolphthalein detect the presence of
both an acid and also a base and finally
bromothymol blue will bromothymol blue
detective a solution is an acid or can
you use bromothymol blue to detect if a
solution is a base or can you use
bromothymol blue to detect both an acid
and a base so these are gonna be your
tasks that you have in our activity in
class